hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for today's video where
I'll be talking about
um you know tools that you could use
along with order flow but before we jump
in you know if you've been learning from
these videos don't forget to subscribe
uh to the channel and be sure to click
the notification Bell so you don't miss
a new upload and honestly if you find
today's video helpful hit the like
button and leave me a comment sharing
you know your biggest takeaway and what
you'd like to see potentially in an
upcoming video you know I love hearing
your feedback so your support really
goes a long way in helping me create
more content just like this so again if
you're getting value from my Channel I
want to see more be sure to subscribe
and you know we'll go through your
trading journey together so to speak so
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic alright so let's jump into
it so this uh the whole purpose of
today's video is based off of a comment
um from one of my earlier videos by uh
yeshawan
Kumar I'll just call you Kumar
um for short on basically suggesting
what should be used along with order
flow he said do you suggest using moving
average view app or an alligator tool
along with order flow well that's a good
question because you know I've always
been a big advocate of you know Traders
have their own way of trading to begin
with whether it's something like V web
or alligator tool even a moving average
right I mean support and resistance is
something that a lot of Traders
understand and use they have their own
way of calculating support and
resistance
and you know we'll talk about V web
because that's something you know a lot
of Traders talk about so this is uh this
is crude oil okay this is a v web this
is the basic ninja Trader
um out of the box v-wap tool okay and
you can see it's green if we're trading
above this line in the middle here it's
green if we're training above view app
red if we're trading below view app and
you can see there's areas in here where
we're trading back and forth around V
web back and forth we're on V web and
this is where a lot of Traders sort of
get stuck right because they they think
that oh this is it we're breaking above
V web they're getting long and then it
sort of comes down in here and maybe
they get stopped out then they're back
up again oh we're breaking out a view
app you know we're going to hit the
first standard deviation it comes back
down and they get stopped out again
um
so you know there's a lot of different
ways that people use view app for
trading unfortunately in my opinion a
lot of Traders have sort of bastardized
v-wap and made it into a
a form of a moving average unfortunately
now you know there are there's great
ways to trade V web right anchored B web
is is a great way I've made videos on
that in the past basically what you're
looking for again whether you're using
VAP or a moving average or calculating
your own Supply
um or support and resistance areas you
know using pivot Points you want to
watch how the market is reacting when
you're around V web
okay or deviations right because again
you know
a lot of Traders right Market hits the
standard deviation they're looking for a
big bounce back towards view app right
but what they don't realize is deviation
is also moving down as well right the
the second third standard deviation and
if price is trending down we could
easily hit the second deviation don't
quite get down to the third but I mean
did price move back up to V web yeah it
did from you know the time it hit the
first deviation here at 76 but are you
going to take Heath all the way down to
40. right before it comes back up to oh
one right it's not like you know if
you're buying in here at you know in the
90s right because we just hit our second
standard deviation it's going back up
back up here the v-wap was at at 20 uh
you know 24 it's coming down
so you know if you're along from you
know 95 and it only trades back up to
you know what is that 11 does get back
up to 22 before it comes back down it
makes new lows so what you want to do
right is you want to watch the order
flow
and sort of understand you know what's
the potential for a move up or a move
down you know is it going to keep going
down right I know a lot of people this
is like their bread and butter it's
first standard deviation and rallies
back up to
um V web okay
so let's just take a look at the order
flow
okay so again this is my footprint chart
for crude let's add the view app on here
again this is just a simple ninjatrader
where you at
again it doesn't matter what you're
using it could v-wap you could be using
um your own support and resistance areas
lines that you're drawing
FIB numbers Etc I'll just make this
three so it's a little easier to see
okay so let's just go back
go back here to this eight o'clock so
yeah you know eight o'clock we're
training above view app start trading
below we hit the first standard
deviation Market rallied
from the first standard deviation back
up to V app what happened when you hit
that first standard deviation you had a
nice bullish order flow you got a
bullish Eva you got a single print in
this bar you got two bind imbalances
that's a good trade to take and we
rallied about 20 points okay and then
we're just rotating around vlap
and what people don't realize is like oh
I'm just looking for a reason to get
short or long life B web no you don't
want to do that
that's
basically we're the vet you know you're
trading in the middle of a I don't say
sideways activity but when you're
training at V web that's where price is
supposed to be you want to be away from
view app to trade back towards it okay
that's your you know
your control price so to speak okay so
then we start coming off we come down to
our first standard deviation and not
only did we come down to it we just blew
right through it
we got one two three four five six
cellular balances we've got two zero
prints in the bar okay am I going to be
looking for this Market to bounce back
up to view app well it could I I'm not
going to throw that out the window but I
don't really see anything bullish coming
in here yet right if anything I see more
bearish information
um you know I see the bearish Prominent
Point of control one two here you know
this is a bearish Eva as well on you
know bearish Eva so if anything I'm not
looking to just oh we're trading below
the first standard deviation I'm looking
for it to Rally back up the view app no
if anything I'm looking for this to
happen where we come down here and hit
our second standard deviation
okay we hit that then we start rallying
back up okay we get back up past the
first standard deviation but we don't
quite hit V app up here at 24 right it's
right up here we only get up to 11. and
we start coming back down
right and as we start coming back down
what do I see
I see an exhaustion print six I see a
bearish Prominent Point of control right
here see imbalance reversal you know
this nine against 63 coming in here
bearish information so now I'm looking
okay we haven't rallied back up to our
Prominent Point of control now I got
bearish or sorry rally back up to our
view app I got bearish information
coming in here
I should be looking for it to hit back
down to our second deviation and
probably potentially blow through that
and we do we get down below
the second standard deviation and keep
going down
okay now we're seeing some bullish
information coming in here bullish
uh
Prominent Point of control bullish
slingshot stack buying and balance
coming in here as well
right here you got a zero print
maybe we could rally at least up to 90.
you know this is from the 60 area
seven years that would give it you know
potentially a 20 point move
but it doesn't it doesn't even get up
there right if anything I was looking
for you know this is an area I'd be
looking to buy honestly
I'm not going to say well you know for
some reason that I didn't admit there it
just didn't get there
okay
and it starts coming back down hits that
deviation that's why you got to have a
stop in the market okay but as you
notice right the deviations are moving
down moving lower okay
and then it's just sort of going
sideways in here yeah you get some
bullish information you're at your
second deviation bullish slingshot point
of control bullish Eva
it starts to go a little bit higher but
it's just going sideways in here okay
then you get this bar you're still
hugging your second deviation
zero prints four of them in there some
buying imbalances okay so again if
you're along from in here
you know you you wouldn't have gotten
stopped out yet in my opinion right
we'd be looking at the low as your stop
potentially for a move back up to at
least 80 you know the 83 area it's just
unfortunately just going sideways and
again part of trading is understanding
the time elements right if you're in a
trade for
between a one minute chart and you're
still in a trade and it's not really
moving after you for 15 minutes it's
probably not a good sign that you still
want to be in that trade
okay and what's that it's just going
sideways in here all right that's not a
good sign hits the deviation again but
again still hasn't necessarily stopped
you out bullish Prominent Point of
control another zero prints another zero
print and again it's just hanging in
there it's not necessarily going to be
the greatest trade eventually you do get
up to that 78 area this deviation had
moved lower
again you know that's that's one where
if you're in the trade for a long period
of time and it's not moving on you get
out okay but this is um
you know this v-wap but again it doesn't
have to be v-wap right maybe you're
you're using
let me just take off this uh view app
maybe you're just using something simple
like fibs okay
doesn't matter
what you're using right just shorten
this so it's add uh
retracements right go from the high
through this low as you can see it came
right back up here 61.8 got within a
tick I think this high is what 24
61.8 is 81 24 so this high was 23. but
anyway it got within a tick there right
beautiful right the FIB guys yeah I see
this is it this is a
is what you should be trading but um
really what you want to be watching is
how's the market reacting up here when
it gets back up to your level 61.8 if
that's your trading strategy you're not
saying that you just go add a 61.8 to
every single chart
but let's uh let's let's do it okay take
off this view app
and we're going to add the FIB on there
let's take off that view app first
okay then once this chart comes back
I'm gonna add well let me make it
shorter so I
guess that's our high right that's our
low so let's just add the FIB
right from
here
oh it's here showing us 25 but just draw
that line out here F6 extend it
okay
so okay well to me the important ones
are 50 and 61.8 okay so when it gets up
to 50
so these are my two levels
okay
it just blows right through it right
coming back up to 50.
very strong buying right you see the
exhaustion print not exhaustion print
down here is four but up here you got
thin prints you got a couple buying
imbalances you blow right through it
okay I'm not looking for this Market to
sell off from here yet
but I know I get you know 25 I want to
watch how the market comes back up there
right and we get within a tick here we
get to 24. all right and then what
happens
well I see an exhaustion print here of
two
zero zero the thin prince in the bar
okay so it's starting to react off of
this
all right this is my level
all right ideally I'd love to see the
exhaustion print right at the level but
you gotta watch what's happening when
you're trading around your level
okay it starts coming back down
you got two imbalances coming in here
obviously the negative Delta two more
imbalances in here bearish bottom point
of control
okay so it's traded this and this is
coming in right below the 50 level
so this is my area here between 09 and
25.
right then I'm looking for potential
signs of rejection and I'm seeing it
here starting here in this bar
so I'm not looking for this Market to
keep going up I got my go signed already
right and then the market starts working
its way back down and it's just littered
with bearish order flow
um
you know just really quick
you know I did send out an email to
my email list earlier about
um you know this tool package from Ninja
caters people why are you sending me
this Mike but it's really they have this
pure pattern Trader right and I sort of
worked out a deal with the guys at Ninja
caters
there's three parts of it there's
Elliott wave harmonic pattern and pure
pattern Trader but um pure pattern
Trader is the one that I want to focus
on
okay and just really quick
what you could do right they got all
these different patterns you know since
we're sort of talking about you know
what can you use you could use any form
of technical analysis whether it's
moving average whether it's V web
Etc and
let me just shut down these other things
this
I just want to show you something really
quick
just you know it's sort of the drive
home the point of
you know you could use whatever form of
analysis that you want
just be consistent
okay and watch how the order flow is
reacting
around those areas
okay and whoops
oh my god let's make this medium extreme
shrink up still
playing around with the swing strength
between medium and uh
well just give it a second here because
it's
going to take a second to come up but
you know really the point is it doesn't
really matter how you find your levels
as long as it's your way of finding your
levels as long as it's a way that you
understand how those levels are formed
whether it's a technical pattern whether
it's a v web whether it's an anchored B
whether it's volume profile whether it's
Market profile okay and really what you
want to be watching
is what's happening in the order flow so
I have this set okay I have it just set
to show double
um bottoms or double tops and this
s PS
right we had this double bottom forming
down here today
is here to here right it's a double
Bottom now you could the cool thing is
you could sort of adjust it to sort of
figure out the ratios but look at this
on
the first double bottom right you had
the Prominent Point of control but on
the second
double bottom
the second bottom of the double bottom
the second double bottom he also had a
bullish Prominent Point of control
okay so I'm forming a double bottom and
I got a lot of bullish order flow coming
in what do you think that is the sign of
well it's a sign probably going to go
higher right and we did we rallied off
of this double bottom right because
there's times where you have double
bottoms and the market keeps bottoming
out or you have a double top and the
market
is either going to sell off or or it's
going to Rally against you right so if
you have a you know some sort of tool
that you're looking at or you know your
own way of your own analysis right
there's nothing against doing your own
analysis finding you know a head and
shoulders pattern wrap order flow around
it
okay
simple right okay I got a double bottom
and on this double bottom I know that I
had you know bullish Prominent Point of
controls literally on the bottom on the
bottom right here right then I see as
we're sort of breaking out past this
line here
all right this is your validation line
what do you get all right you got buying
imbalances you got thin prints in the
bar
and it's just Off to the Races so all
right everyone
um you know again I I hope you guys are
getting some value out of you know these
videos
um you know I enjoyed making this video
because you know this is a question I
get I asked you know actually quite a
bit about you know what else can I use
um with order Flow It's supposed to just
pure order flow there's no law that says
if you're an order flow Trader you have
to only use order flow no that's
you could use whatever you want
with order flow right and that's where
you're gonna get the most value from
order flow is wrapping it around the way
you're already Trading
right and you know it kills me because
you know I I do see some of the negative
comments from people and they say oh you
know water flow is is this or that you
know it's a new fad it's not orderful
has been around for over 100 years right
Jesse Livermore reminisces of a stock
operator if you ever read that book he
was a tape reader right which is what
order flow and
you know or they'll say no you got to
look at this way at the market okay you
can take your existing way price action
but add order flow to it right for a lot
of Traders you know it's really been
sort of the the key that's unlocked the
difference in their trading from being
you know mediocre or you know Break Even
or a loser two
being more successful trading all right
so again you know be sure to subscribe
to this channel keep those comments
coming you know I'm really enjoying them
um and I'll catch you guys on the next
video bye bye